we are heroes providing food I mean we
making a
[Music]
change as immigrants food brings us
around the table it's a way to preserve
our cultures and it's also a form of
survival it shouldn't be expensive to
eat healthy it shouldn't be
exclusive my whole mission isn't just to
sell fruit my mission is to Mentor the
kids that think they don't have a chance
the system is rare and an average
citizen doesn't know about it oh he just
keep going back to jail it's like no you
caught up in the spider wear that's what
down Nerf is about Second Chances she's
got a cape on might be tucked in but
she's got a cape on for
[Music]
sure can you imagine food in America
without the flavors brought in from
refugees and immigrants come on Halal
tacos Halal tacos we Crying Out Loud
Let's grow food on our yards let's hire
our neighbors let's preserve and capture
and reuse water smartly let's let's be
about it
pass good googly
moogly what I love about selling fruit
is I'm just bringing a little bit of
light to the dark world that we live in
you're uniting the two most despised
groups in Orange County Mexicans and
Muslims May there be a taco truck at
every mosque all across the United
States and then hopefully the world to
be able to collectively harness that
power within our community my gosh it's
Unstoppable the chefs that we work with
if they enter The Culinary world right
now they'd be working in the back it's
only at Cav where they're really
celebrated we actually looking to make
change and since we was looked at the
villains why not be the
[Music]
heroes